Here is the clip we're going to deal
with.
Let's play a couple divine coming is
what he's talking about. What do you
mean divine coming? Because in the very
next chapter, that blind man that he
healed said, I am ego as well. That
Greek term ego ami say I'm smart too.
That Greek word ego ami in the very next
chapter John 9:1 when Christ healed that
blind man, he makes the same.
>> Okay. The argument is John 8:58. Jesus
[clears throat] says I am proving he's
God. He's responding saying ego. He said
ego am I. It's ego me. Doesn't mean
Jesus is God because the blind man said
ego me as well. Now listen.
There is nobody that Jesus healed who
claimed to be the great I am who I am.
No way. So dishonest.
>> I want you to hear they're talking past
each other. Clip doesn't understand his
argument and Tesarak is butchering John
8:58. But listen, if you guys can find
the full debate, send me the link
because I already started a playlist
to Zaric versus Cliff. I'm going to go
through it like I went through to Zaric
with inspiring philosophy.
Cliff was quoting John 8:58.
Cliff was quoting John 8:58
where Jesus says before Abra was born I
am. He's saying that's Jesus referring
to his coming. But in John 9:9 the blind
man also said ego I am I not ego am I do
it's not let go my ego the zariaak you
whack baby ego ami. Well the blind man
said ego ami. So Cliff is saying no one
ever said that the great I am. That's a
lie. That's dishonest. See, he didn't
understand to Zaric's point and it's not
a new point. Argument that
antitrinarians have been using from the
beginning, but I'll explain it. Okay,
you ready now for me to go into the
rebuttal.
What is the argument that he was making?
And it's not new to him. Rumble, you
ready?
All right. Right here. By the way, Desar
William are going to be debating this
week on the deity of Christ on Cameron
channel.
Jesus said to them, "Truly, truly I say
to you, before Abraham was, I am." All
right. All right.
The neighbors therefore, and they which
before had seen him, that he was blind,
said, "Is not this he that sat and
begged?" Some said, "This is he?" Others
said, "He is like him." But he said, "I
am he." Okay. Now, I'm going to break
down the argument for you, and we're
going to go through the rebuttal.
[snorts]
John 8:58. Jesus said unto them,
"Verily, verily, I say unto you, before
Abraham was, I am." Okay, what's the
argument? Well, let me show you. Notice
here it says ego
imi. That's what he said, right? Ego.
Ego. But he said I me. See, I I I can
drop some knowledge, too. You see what
I'm saying, Cliff? I I know my I CAN
DROP SOME KNOWLEDGE. I know the Greek.
It's all Greek to me. Ego. Ego ami.
Right. Ego ami. Ego ami. Ego. Amen. Now,
what's the connection with John 9:9?
What's the connection with John 9:9?
Here's the connection. If you look at
the Greek of John 99, it's the same
Greek word.
The blind man when he says, "I am," John
records his words in Greek as ego.
He kept saying
trying to pronounce it like you Greek
modern Greek. Same words right here. You
see it? He said ego. The blind man said,
"Yeah, ego I am."
Jesus said, "Egoy me."
Obviously the blind man
obviously the blind man
wasn't saying I am God. You understand
the argument the objection when the
blind man said ego ami was he saying I'm
God? No. So why do you Christians think
that when Jesus says ego ami
Jesus was claiming to be God? You
understand their objection? If you
understand your objection, I can go into
the rebuttal.
If you understand their objection, I can
go into the rebuttal.
Both Jesus and the blind man said, "I am
me."
[clears throat]
Exactly, Lucas. That's their argument.
Now, you guys can see how
how stupid that argument is. You know
why?
And I got to blame Christians as well
because Christians are poorly catechized
and educated.
Don't know how to exede or defend their
position.
The words ago
do not prove in of themselves that
Christ claimed to be God. Ago is simply
saying I am. Hey, are you Samy?
The words in of themselves are not
indicative of deity. Doesn't mean you're
God. It's the way you use them.
So yes, it's true.
Yes, it's true
that when the blind man said, he's
simply saying, "Yeah, I'm the blind
man." Because they're saying, "Is he
him?"
Uh
maybe.
Yeah. Ego me. It's me. You get it.
Learn how not to do apologetics. Learn
how not to exede in the beginning. Good
to see you, brother. And learn the
proper way of doing ex Jesus and
apologetics.
The argument isn't that Jesus said I am.
Now knowing Cliff because he's not
trained in apologetics, he probably made
the mistake by saying, "Well, in Exodus
3:14, God says I am and Jesus says I
am." Ego ami ego in of themselves do not
prove deity. It's the way the Lord used
the expression. And again, you know how
many articles I have on the ego and how
many articles I have on the connection
with the Old Testament and sessions,
especially in response to Greg Stafford.
All you need to do is go here to the
blog, right? Go here to the blog, even
on the main website answering
Islam.info. You put in ego
ami. What comes up?
John's ago sayings revisited even more
proof that Jesus is Jehovah God most
high. See that's it. Save these articles
before they're gone. You see
that's it.
Here's an example. [snorts]
See
just to give it to you right here.
right there
or right here. If you go here,
right here, John's ego statements
revisited.
There you go. [snorts]
And here I linked to other other ones.
Jesus Christ, Israel's ani
who saves Jesus as the great I am. Let
me just link to this and you can find
all the articles there. It's also on my
website.
It's not new, man. It's old stuff.
But let's go and see the context.
All right. Let's go and see the context.
Let's first see why did the Lord say
before Abram was born, I am.
Your father Abraham rejoiced to see my
day. And he saw and was glad. Then said
the Jews unto him, "Thou art not yet 50
years old. And hast thou seen Abraham?
This is the context. Jesus said to the
said unto them, "Verily, verily, I said
to you, before Abram was, I am." This is
the context. What's the context?
The context is Jesus said, "Abraham
saw him and saw the day of his coming
and was elated, rejoiced
in seeing the Lord and seeing his day."
This has two meanings.
But now understand how the Jews
understood our Lord's words.
Okay, note how they understood his
words. Then said the Jews unto him,
"Thou art not yet 50 years old, and hast
thou seen Abraham?" Understand how they
understood it. And Jesus doesn't correct
it. You're not yet 50 years old. Abraham
has been dead for about 2,000 years. How
could you possibly know Abraham's
reaction? Are you saying you saw him?
Okay, understand [clears throat] what
they took from his statements.
Everyone with me?
They understood our Lord to be saying,
"I was there and saw Abraham's reaction,
but you're not yet 50 years old.
How could you have seen Abraham?" Now,
if the Jews misunderstood our Lord,
here's the key of explaining this. If
the Jews misunderstood our Lord, then
our Lord could have corrected them,
right? Do not let them get away with
murder. They're going to tell you, "No,
Jesus is saying before Abraham was born,
I am the Messiah." Meaning, God had
already announced my coming, my creation
to be Messiah. Our Lord could have
explained and said, "No,
I didn't see him. You're not getting
it." God revealed to Abraham and showed
Abraham that I would come. And when he
saw
my coming in the future, he was excited
and laid it when he was given that
vision. Not that I was there. Right? The
Lord could have said that, right?
Please understand how to present this
passage.
He didn't say that. He actually
confirmed they understood him correctly.
What do I mean? You are right
in inferring that I was there and saw
Abraham's reaction because that's what
they're asking him. You're not even 50.
You saw Abraham. Yes, I did see him.
You're right to infer. That's what I'm
claiming. And let me let the kid out of
the bag. Don't let my physical body, my
human appearance mislead you. I'm much
older than 50.
Because though as a man, I'm not yet 50.
I'm more than a man.
And as God, I've always been there. In
fact, I've been there from before your
father Abraham was created.
So, not only did I see his reaction, I
was there from the very beginning before
he came into existence because unlike
Abraham who has a beginning, I am
without beginning, without end. That's
the contrast.
Glory to Jesus Christ. When you go to
church, pray for me and ask the saints
to pray for me, brother. I need all the
saints, all the churches.
Right here you see it says
before Abraham
ganist
let's see what this is
ginome
go it's from ginome what does that mean
to come into existence
to come into being to be made
caused to be you see it
before Abraham came into existence.
Now notice the contrast. Our Lord did
not say
right ego [clears throat]
in I was. He didn't say ego
in because he could have said I was in
meaning was. You get my point.
He deliberately and John deliberately
used the correct appropriate Greek verb
to communicate what Jesus would have
said. Ame I am.
Okay, you understand now what I'm
getting at. Now you Greek speakers, let
me know if I'm spot on.
Ego
means I was.
He could have said before Abraham was I
was.
He deliberately used
I am which in Aramaic would have been an
Hebrew or an I. He.
He deliberately used the in Greek which
the corresponding Hebrew would have been
who he an I he. Ani who? Ani who.
All right. Okay, now watch here. Why is
this important? Because he's not just
simply saying, "I existed before
Abraham." He wanted to say more than
that. Yes, I existed before Abraham. Do
you know why?
Because my existence is unlike Abraham.
Abraham's existence had a beginning. He
came into existence. He's a creature. My
existence
is always
it simply is
I am existence.
I've been there
remain and continue forever.
That's why he used the present tense.
If he simply wanted to say that he was
there before Abraham, he could have said
ego
[clears throat] ego, right?
You with me there?
How could you have been there 2,000
years earlier? Because I'm not merely
human. I'm not a creature like you. I'm
not a creature like Abraham. He came
into being. I've never come into being
because John 1 already prepared you. Who
is he? John 1 tells you this one is the
word that was there from before creation
who was with God the father who's God in
nature who then created all things and
gives life to all things in creation
illuminates it and then he at one
specific moment in time became flesh.
That's the context, right?
Let's go a little deeper into the
context to make this point clear. Let's
go a little earlier. I want you to catch
John 8:40.
Look what he says.
If you are Abraham's children, you would
do the works of Abraham. You behave like
Abraham. But now you seek to kill me, a
man who has told you the truth that I
heard from God. This is not what Abraham
did. Now, I've done millions of sessions
on this. You should know the answer.
Look what he said.
He said, "Here's the proof. You don't
belong to Abraham.
You are trying to kill me after seeing
me. Abraham didn't try to do that. Did
you understand what he just said?
Abraham did not react to me the way
you're reacting to me. You see me now in
the flesh. You want to kill me. Abraham
didn't try to kill me.
See the implication?